the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie
what's odd ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones video
as you can see by the title of the video
I want to talk about the new deleted
scenes from Game of Thrones I don't know
how many of you have seen these yet but
I do have to say they're very
interesting
the deleted scenes I want to show you
today all have to do with Brian Stark
now as we all know bran has had many
different dreams visions and flashbacks
over the years this started happening
right after Jamie had thrown bran from
the tower window it was at this time
when the three-eyed Raven started to
visit brain in his dreams this is when
brand started to open his third eye
which allows him to see certain events
from the past present and even the
future most of us have been trying to
decipher what all the different visions
actually mean some say these visions
could be possible clues to how Game of
Thrones will end
since HBO decided to delete these scenes
maybe that's because they gave away too
much information well I guess since we
are only a couple weeks away from the
final season they decided to release the
deleted scenes what I want to do today
is take a look at the scenes to see if
we can find any clues about how the show
could end now before we get started I do
want to give everyone a heads up some of
the scenes I will show you today could
be seen as a little creepy to say the
least if I were you I would not watch
the video at work or around any little
kids as we all know ever since brain
stark has become the new three-eyed
Raven he has started to act a lot
different than he used to one of the
biggest examples of this was when brain
and Songza reunited last season during
their conversation out by the weirwood
tree brain said something to Sansa that
appeared to send chills down her spine
for some reason bran thought it was a
good idea to talk about one of the most
traumatizing moments in Songz's life in
case any of you forgot take a look at
the scene it was so beautiful that night
it's no fooling just like now and you
were so beautiful
in your white wedding dress
I have to go back inside Brian I'll stay
a bit longer I really don't know why
bran shows to talk about that but it
just goes to show you what type of
thoughts and images he has floating
around inside of his head I guess we all
should have seen that coming because
brain has been watching characters have
sex ever since the very first episode of
the show we all can't forget the scene
when bran caught Cersei and Jaime having
sex together which essentially kicked
off the entire story stop
[Music]
are you completely mad
your sauce it's alright it's alright
it's alright he saw us
I heard you the first time then of
course we have the scene from last
season where we got one of our biggest
revelations brand Saul Rhaegar and
Lyanna get married at the exact same
time John and Daenerys were having sex
so it does become quite clear that bran
has some sort of connection to some of
the other characters most intimate
moments now let's take a look at the
scenes because there may be some new
clues about how Game of Thrones ends the
first scene takes place right after
brain and Meera escape from the
three-eyed Ravens cave this was when
bran was having to download basically
the entire history of Westeros as Meera
is trying to run from all the whites
brain is downloading all the different
images from some of the biggest events
over the course of the story the only
difference is HBO deleted one of the
scenes from brains vision I'm not really
sure why bran had to see that scene but
it might be very telling let's take a
look
[Music]
you
[Music]
Wow okay
for some reason bran was watching Danny
and Drago have sex I guess we should not
be surprised when it comes to brain
Stark now what does it actually mean
well maybe it has something to do with
Danny's vision at the house of the
undying
maybe Daenerys and called Drogo are
meant to reunite in the afterlife or
bran just wanted to watch Danny have sex
I don't know let's move on to the next
deleted scene this one might reveal a
little more information that we can
actually use this deleted scene is from
the very first season of the show I
believe this is from what a brain storks
dreams now most of what he sees are
things that are telling him to find a
three-eyed Raven this would all
eventually lead to brand becoming the
new three-eyed Raven but HBO deleted one
scene that may be indicating something
else there has to be a good reason why
bran was originally shown this clue
let's see what it is
look for me you would be a wonderful
King
what the hell was that all about
why did Brian need to see Renly and
Loras was that meant to be some of the
foreshadowing for Renly raising his
banners against the crown and his own
brother that sort of is what Loras was
talking about in that scene but what
else could it mean
maybe Loras going down on Renly was
symbolizing something maybe that means
bran will have to escape from Winterfell
than head down south but where would he
go I'm not exactly sure just yet but
let's watch some of the other deleted
scenes because maybe they all connect in
some way
now the next deleted scene is when bran
Hodor Jojen and Meera are travelling
north beyond the wall this is when bran
has heard or set him down in front of
the weirwood tree I believe this is the
first time we see Bryan touch a tree to
download visions what he sees this time
is slightly different than what HBO
originally released let's have a look
maybe this one is easier to dissect
[Music]
[Music]
no for me it is true what they say about
the northern girls okay I don't know
what the hell that was all about but I
am starting to notice a bit of a pattern
here bran is either the biggest creep in
Westeros or maybe that just means
they're all [ __ ] now we did see Roz
and Tyrion in the scene
maybe this one is symbolizing something
as well we saw Roz going down on Tyrion
so maybe bran really does have to go
south to beat the night king I don't
know what else this could mean now there
is one last vision and I do believe this
one gives us the biggest clue now this
one takes place when brain is training
with the three-eyed Raven this is when
bran notices the three-eyed Raven has
his eyes closed so brain takes advantage
of the opportunity that way he can go
exploring instead of the weirwood net by
himself if you remember correctly this
was when the night king reaches out and
grabs bran by the arm that was what we
ended up getting to see in the show but
HBO originally had a different scene in
mind for some reason they decided to
delete one of the other things that bran
saw during that scene so let's take a
look to see what brain sees
[Music]
I do believe my Lords are loved for many
years most of my life really play with
her ass holy [ __ ]
now that is very interesting what the
hell could that actually mean
why did bran see Littlefinger telling
Raw's to stick a finger in her ass could
that have been the foreshadowing for
bran having to reveal all of little
fingers dirty little secrets or does
that mean bran will have to leave
Winterfell to travel down to the gods
brown eye I don't know but I have a
feeling that fans will be analyzing that
vision for many years to come let me
know what you think about all of this I
need everyone to help me decipher these
new deleted scenes leave your thoughts
down below anyways I want to thank
everyone for watching today's video
I really appreciate that and also want
to thank everyone on patreon for
supporting the channel I hope everyone
has a great April Fool's Day and I hope
to see you all come back for the next
one bye
you
[Music]